[Musik]
hallo herr dr
ich übernehme die werbekampagne für ein
ganz bestimmtes produkt sie sind machen
soziologe um dieses produkt geht es dann
können wir das image verbessern von
astrazeneca
wir müssen schauen was an positiven
vorurteile bezüglich dieses impfstoffes
noch da ist und dann müssen wir das nach
vorne hin zur werbung gehört natürlich
auch die feldstudie wie stehen die
menschen wirklich zu astrazeneca haben
sie schon mal darüber nachgedacht sich
impfen zu lassen
lasst mich auf jeden fall müssen sie
lassen sich impfen und herr bebens habe
ich gute nachricht ich hab das volk
dabei wir können es jetzt durchziehen
darf ich auch ja sie dürfen auch
kämpferisch auch zwei ampullen dabei mir
wurde gestern gerade gesund abgenommen
jährlich soll ich direkt da reinstecken
wo das nein nicht schon wieder
sie wissen ich hoffe es ist also das ist
mir ganz nur ich habe heute morgen
frisch aus der zdf kantine besorgt hat
die nebenwerk uhren astrazeneca roja was
halten sie zusätzlich von einem kultigen
ritual
also ich denke da an den kleinen pfeil
klingenden kennen sie vor jeder impfung
klopft man mit dem fläschchen dreimal
auf den tisch und dann ab in die vene
wenn wir für dieses tolle ritual einen
grund finden also das vielleicht sich
erst in dem moment wo wir drei mal
klopfen der impfstoff irgendwie vermögen
ja es muss man muss schon immer einen
triftigen grund mitgeben was ist das
fragt das ist der astra zeneca ach du
lieber tot league russisch und sie ich
bin der kölner
was halten sie hier von astrazeneca
lasse ich rein das ist schon eine
richtung deutsche vertrauens träger die
sich für einen impfstoff einsetzen da
können wir was machen also gekauft
gekauft ohne gesprochen ja die ohne den
sport das gehört ja dazu
naja was heißt denn ohne die
schwellenländer sonst
warum sollte es denn sonst manuel neuer
sein werde so sagen dass er sich hat
impfen lassen das ist immer das stärke
aber daneben sich die deutschen wieder
auf er ist ja gar nicht in gruppe eins
und zwei und sie dürfen das auch anders
ja dürfen dürfen
das heißt dürfen also wie sie haben
jetzt halt die chance ja wer sagt mir
dass da das mittel richtig drehen sich
nur 200 von der heute show wenn ich
kenne ich schon ich also ja das ist so
eine seriöse show es ist ja total
unwahrscheinlich dass eine ernste
nebenwirkungen auftritt 0,00 0 5 prozent
deswegen habe ich folgenden claim
astrazeneca wahrscheinlich eine gute
wahl oder ist das zu ehrlich also gerade
wenn wir pharma medizin werbung machen
sind wir mit wahrscheinlichkeiten und
eventuell hilft das medikament da
kriegen wir höchstwahrscheinlich küssen
nein astrazeneca viel glück das ist
niedlich aber ich würde sagen das ist
auch nur eine variante davon als sie
würden auch astrazeneca nehmen wenn es
nichts anderes gibt sich jetzt durch ich
sehe sie jeden freitag im fernsehen zu
ihnen habe ich vertrauen also weiß
jemand muss genauer ein muss in den
muskeln also wahrscheinlich in dem motto
ich bin irgendwie jetzt noch unsicher
geworden dass auch wir hatten super
brainstorming wie lautet jetzt unser
slogan gründlich technisch abgeprüft in
deutschland am besten auch noch super
und dann sehen wir noch an die scheuer
der nach den sternen greift ich glaube
wenn man im moment in deutschland etwas
zu erfolg bringen will sollte man nichts
zu stark ein co branding mit der marke
an die scheuer eingeben ich habe ich
hab's karl lauterbach im arztkittel
greift nach den sternen
perfekt da kann ich die angst wir haben
super
[Musik]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist nicht so viele abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten